so like have you guys ever wondered what
John Wick looks like under all that CGI
well ever since I found these behind the
scenes videos of how they make the John
Wick movies I've been obsessed and it's
not just because I'm a big Keanu Reeves
fan I'm a huge Keanu Reeves fan
you're a breathtaking I know that if
you're watching this you're a big piano
fan too which is why you'll be happy to
know that he actually did all his own
stunts for the John Wick movies no CGI
there at all he can do everything he's
just as good as any stuff
any stuff even at age 50 Keanu Reeves is
a professionally trained martial artist
but he didn't get those Mad Skills from
taking a spin class and being over 50
the physical limitations that one gets
at that age has to be overcome with even
more hours of physical fitness training
for five months before filming he
literally trained eight hours a day for
five days a week that's like working out
as a full-time job when we train him
we'll go for hours and hours and hours
and he just won't stop during those five
months Keanu focused on fighting martial
arts and all sorts of totally awesome
moves you don't get to show up in do
what he does without having to stay or
work ethic and obviously he's also a
certified Stunt Driver he's a phenomenal
driver and Stunt Driver and that allowed
us to be able to put him in a lot more
of the shops it took them like three
months to choreograph this taxi
Warehouse scene with Keanu at the wheel
the whole time if Tokyo drifted through
the streets of Manhattan wasn't cool
enough the stunt team also elevated this
ramp to give the Mustang some serious
air when it launched onto the street
although I'm not sure I'd feel totally
safe if he was my Uber driver no offense
Keanu okay confession time Keanu Reeves
doesn't do all his own stunts well yeah
I could get hit by a car but you know
hospital when a scene demands just a bit
more action than Keanu can give he calls
in the pros for some backup John Wick
will get hit by a car and that's Jackson
spidell you guys just a side note
Jackson spidell is like the king of
stunts besides John Wick he's been in a
ton of Marvel movies honestly I think
he's too cute to be a stunt actor but
that's just me sorry Moving on but
speaking of cute
is that the dog
he likes you
no CGI here the John Wick dogs are
totally real as far as the dog movies
that I've worked on this is one of the
most ambitious without a doubt
apparently there's this Corporation
Called animal actors International
that's like this database of animals who
act I wonder if Danny DeVito is
represented by them kidding we love you
Danny but that's where the John Wick
people found all their canine actors who
honestly all deserve Oscars they're so
talented a very special Beagle named
Andy played the part of Daisy who
unfortunately had a limited amount of
screen time I'll tell you what happened
to Andy after they finished filming John
Wick in a sec but first I gotta touch on
the CGI so we all know CGI can be used
for a ton of different things even stuff
you wouldn't expect like lighting
de-aging technology is sorry shiny
Robert De Niro fog even kissing we set
such higher standards on the first two
movies that you always have to kind of
one up with it but apparently this
technology is a lot more complicated
than I thought we got to put things on
the edge of what's real and still make
it cinematic okay I know most of the CGI
and the John Wick movies are super legit
but there was one thing they faked that
I just couldn't get over this right here
was CGI and it cost the filmmakers five
thousand dollars seriously guys couldn't
you just get chocolate or something well
they did spend the rest of that 25
million dollar budget pretty well though
sucks did you know green screens are
green because green is the furthest
color away from many different skin
tones so when CGI is added in post the
character's skin won't get canceled out
in the Final Cut so does that mean I
should wear as much green as possible if
I'm camera shy well what if I want to be
totally invisible I should probably wear
one of these full body green screen
outfits the VFX team used to film this
motorcycle scene yeah we just wanted to
put some dudes in green suits really it
was pretty great I just wanted to
embarrass the stunt team this motorcycle
scene was actually inspired by a similar
fight scene from the 2017 South Korean
film The Villain s which Keanu and John
Wick director Chad stachowski had both
seen and loved we started trying to
figure it out oh this is what they did
this is really interesting it was like a
puzzle we tried to piece together well
I'll tell you why this was the most
difficult scene to film but first I
gotta give you that update on on Andy
the Beagle well shortly after Andy
retired from Show Business he was
adopted into a loving family who renamed
him Wick that's so cute Daisy
of course dogs weren't the only live
animal on the set of John Wick do you
guys remember when Keanu rides a literal
horse throughout the streets of the city
not only did Keanu have to learn stunt
driving for these films he also had to
learn stunt horse riding Chad was like
time to train on a horse for real it's
all legit it's it's John Wick it's like
it's just instead of just riding a horse
you have to have a gun fight well
apparently it took Keanu hundreds of
hours to learn how to ride but that just
goes to show how talented and devoted he
really is riding a horse was too easy
for Keanu Reeves so we had him do trick
riding ain't that one good looking
cowboy
been something we've been working on for
a couple months to try and get this
thing right so the motorcycle fight
scenes were definitely the most
difficult scenes to shoot we have a CGI
sequence it's been challenging because
it's so outside of what we normally do
the filmmakers used a combination of
Studio green screen stunts the stunt
team worked out the choreography first
then everything else will come after
that and live action shots on location
in New York for some high-speed action
I'm serious they had stunt bikers going
over 100 kilometers an hour for these
shots then they see Jihad keanu's face
onto one of the stunt drivers for the
final cut everything we did had to have
a visceral reaction to the audience okay
guys now this is some real movie Magic
for this motorcycle scene in particular
the VFX team had to add CGI to shots
that were 1 000 frames long that's 1 000
different images that had to be altered
individually and seamlessly edited
together to create a Contin newest image
and here I thought editing Instagram
reels was like serious editing there's
more of a partnership with stunts and
visual effects than people know turns
out there's no chat GPT for movie making
who computer make me an epic fight
sequence so how do they make it safe for
the actors to pull off these sweet moves
you remember that famous fight scene
that seemed to take place in that knife
Museum well all that glass special
effects well some of it was real also
special custom made glass to show up
better on screen and only explode on you
it was visually edited in post by the
VFX Department to give it that shiny
cinematic look so many of the physical
props in John Wick were real which
probably made it easier for the audience
to get lost in the magic of John Wick
well I can't help but be totally
impressed with these actors like how
hard would it be to keep a straight face
while you're doing this kind of scene I
think if there's any other action actor
or actor there wouldn't be a John work I
think he's the only one that could play
him alright I literally didn't think it
was possible for me to love Keanu Reeves
any more than I already did sometimes
life has a funny way of surprising you I
guess but what about you guys are you
impressed with his sick moves